alors moi mon choix j'ai eu une belle à
une belle amitié récentes et une petite
déception car tu as il regarde il sera
alors l'amitié alors je de l'hers et
valérie pu délibérer oui parce que
j'étais entre avenches a trouvé plutôt
fade
dans mon coeur mais voilà dix ans elles
n'avaient jamais trop d'idées oui
c'était un peu ma chronique mais
pourtant des n'y a ni à tout le monde
est gentil tout le monde est beau elle
sourit elle un brushing il avait des
cheveux bon bref et maintenant c'est un
brésil voit quelqu'un elle y aller drôle
et piquante elle a des avis elle les
donne à s'acheter une belle paire de
yoox open alors là d'ailleurs dû me
prendre puisque je reconnais que j'en ai
un petit peu moins sourit c'est vrai
c'est vrai donc voilà et c'est qui la
déception alors ma petite déception si
nous regarde c'est mon ami jean bie non
ouais j'en vis mon deuil ouais ouais
ouais j'en ai parlé à kelly a pas
longtemps alors la cdefi comment je sais
que c'est la place des jolies filles
d'accord je n'ai pas là qu'il y a pas
l'on dit ça pour benjamin castaldi
[Rires]
je crois que c'est la méchanceté du tout
sa part mais quand j'ai quitté bas
depuis qu'il est plus dans l'émission
est là et que moi j'étais pas la
dernière mais jamais une nouvelle jamais
valorisé la hanche jeudi on dîne oui
on dit la même chose
et c'est dommage il ya encore un
week-end j'ai on se voit ça répond par
oui non je ne sens pas dans
c'était une vraie vraie vraie celle dont
vous étiez copains vraiment mais comme
kalou et c'est bête parce que quand tu
critiques aux ti cats après tu as du mal
à
l'impression que ça vous chagrine ah oui
beaucoup c'est vrai vous donne une
interview l'a dit dans l'interview le
dis je ne sais pas entretenir des
amitiés mais je confirme oui mais oui je
suis un petit peu la pression j'ai eu
l'impression que jean mi items cité dans
son champ de vision alors d'après eux
jean pascal qui est arrivé c'était son
meilleur ami cité dans son champ de
vision était son ami si tu disais alors
je suis pas du tout d'accord d'un ami
aujourd'hui c'est mon âme d amy adams
est vrai que je sais que à chaque fois
que je l'appelle pas il est toujours là
et il a été je vais vous dire la vérité
parce qu'il était un petit peu déçue
parce que vous l'avez aussi laissé
tomber quand vous n'êtes pas bien
peut-être vrai qu'on en parle je croise
d'enquêté dans l'autre jour et la
croixille sortait du système judiciaire
ouais ça va être un vrai savage c'est
pas possible on peut pas se dire de
ouais ça va on savait pas
non mérité mieux
est ce que j'ai dit tout ce qu'on sait
c'est une bonne chose cette invention un
petit gars est un vrai choix des noms
mais bon je dormais chez lui souvent
d'inr là est une habitude avec son chien
est garé tout ça et j'avais besoin que
quand j'ai quitté l'émission j'ai quitté
sa vie
non mais parce que là c'est vrai que
c'est parce que j'en ai c'est important
d'en parler ils ont mis si nos gardes
c'est vrai qu'on aurait une explication
face à la semaine prochaine car pour la
dernière demi-heure j'adore jean michel
aulas d'ailleurs merci merci à badalone
son cours jeudi pour jeudi vous il faut
changer de lunettes parce que je voulais
enfin bon voire je vous nomme alors je
vous dis la vérité je vous adore vous
étiez en train de revenir finalement
j'ai la cellule est normé témoins
l'armée d'élite hommes et femmes et des
hommes étaient les bons
à teramo tiello du coup ils voient plus
rien et regarde la
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cacher qu'elle veut et très très fier
et voulait
[Applaudissements]
elle voit tout nu